[Musique]
wow
[Musique] [Musique
]
oh [Musique
] euh [Musique
]
beurre de cacahuète
euh [
Musique] [
Musique] [Musique] [Musique
] [Musique] [
Musique]
pouah
[Musique]
euh
euh euh
[Musique]
euh [Musique] [
Musique]
h [
Musique
] très bien [Applaudissements] étranger [Musique] euh
hmm [
Musique]
est [
oh [
Musique]
oh [Musique
] [Musique
]
[Musique]
étranger
[  La musique]
ce sont
des questions
[Applaudissements]
c'est
[Musique] [
Musique]
c'est [
Musique] [Musique]
de
oh
[Applaudissements]
ok [
Musique] [Musique] [Musique] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hmm [
Musique]
[  Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
hmm [Musique
]
euh
euh [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok [
Applaudissements] [
Musique]
frénésie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hmm
désolé
[Musique]
je
c'est-à-dire
[  Applaudissements] il
n'y a pas de soleil quand elle est partie
[Musique]
il ne fait pas chaud quand elle est réveillée
[Musique] il
n'y a pas de soleil quand elle est partie
et elle est toujours partie trop longtemps
à chaque fois qu'elle s'en va,
je me demande cette fois où elle est partie
[Musique  ]